les forêts elle couvre plus du tiers de
toute la superficie du canada et elle
joue un rôle économique culturel et
écologique de premier plan dans le cadre
des grandes entrevues de notre 50e
anniversaire je me suis entretenu avec
christian messier un spécialiste de ces
grands espaces pour parler de
l'évolution de nos pratiques forestières
et de ce qu'il faudrait faire pour
s'assurer d'avoir des fort et prospère
[Musique]
on a commencé à voir que quand on gère
la forêt on doit pas la gérer seulement
pour les arbres mais pour l'ensemble de
l'écosystème
c'est la biodiversité c'est le sol c'est
l'eau c'est toutes les composantes qui
font l'écosystème
la forester vis à vis de l'agriculture
donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait l'agriculture
on élimine la nature et on se concentre
sur une plante en particulier qu'on
essaie de faire passer le plus
rapidement possible donc c'est ce que la
foresterie au fait au prix la nature
audi a trop d'espèces il ya trop de
diversité et on va éliminer tout ça pour
se concentrer sur des espèces d'armes
commercial qui nous intéresse
[Musique]
donc on a simplifié la forêt et l'on
s'aperçoit que c'est mauvais pour la
biodiversité c'est mauvais pour la
production
une forêt avec moins d'espèces produits
- et c'est surtout une forêt qui est
beaucoup moins capable de s'adapter aux
changements qui s'accélère christian
mais s'y exprimera qu'est ce que c'est
une forêt en santé une fois en santé
c'est vraiment de forêt qui cale de se
régénérer naturellement qui est capable
de résister à toutes sortes de
perturbations qui existe maintenant ou
même qui va exister dans le futur est ce
à ce que sa demande c'est une bonne
diversité d'espèces qui ont des
caractéristiques écologiques très
diversifié je fais souvent l'analogie
avec un fonds d'investissement
si vous voulez un fonds d'investissement
santé qui va vous donner des rendements
à long terme stables vous devez
diversifiée se font là la forêt c'est la
même chose
[Musique]
nos forêts ici au québec au canada ce
qu'elles sont la santé
je voudrais que globalement oui on fait
de la foresterie depuis longtemps mais
on fait de la forêt c'est eux qui est
beaucoup moins intensive que dans
d'autres pays
si vous allez en suède en finlande en
allemagne
ils ont totalement transformé leurs
forêts long simplifiant a éliminé
beaucoup d'espèces qui était moins
intéressant au niveau commercial et donc
y ont diminué la diversité des espèces
nous ici on a essayé de le faire on n'a
pas réussi
je dis souvent qu'on n'a pas été assez
bon mais c'est pas qu'on était pas bon
c'est qu'on avait énormément de forêt
donc on continue à voir quand même une
bonne diversité d'espèces mais ce qui
m'inquiète c'est on l'ehpad petit à
petit un peu près à chaque dix ans on a
un insecte maladies exotiques qui arrive
l'agrile du frêne un coléoptère arrivés
d'asie et le dernier en date est cette
liste s'allonge
elle comprend aussi la maladie corticale
dû être la maladie hollandaise de l'orme
autant de mots et d'insectes pour
lesquelles nos arbres n'ont pas
développé de résistance
ce qui m'inquiète le plus ce qui devrait
inquiéter à peu près tout le monde c'est
le longicorne asiatique
c'est un insecte qui vient d'asie qui
est à dans les feuillus particulièrement
les érables ont le contrôle jusqu'à
maintenant mais sûrement une question de
temps
je dis souvent aux personnes qui ont des
érablières vous devriez aménager votre
forêt avec l'idée que peut-être dans 20
30 40 50 ans vous allez perdre aux
érables et ça c'est problématique parce
que de plus en plus les gens qui ont des
érables à sucre et al pour le sirop
d'érable mais enlève toutes les espèces
compagnes garde seulement à l'érable à
sucre
donc si vous avez un essai qui arrive
qui détruit votre robe le sucre vous
retrouvez devant rien et ça c'est
inquiétant avec le châtaignier lorsqu'on
est un bel exemple de ce qui peut ali
mais terriblement mal vous aviez ou
détenir dans toute la chaîne des
appalaches des milliards de châtaigniers
qui est un arbre qui devient très gros
et les châtains que son commercial il y
avait des festivals il y avait des
pleins d'activités très très très
intéressante les gens faisait des fight
autour de la châtaigne et dans les
années 1910 petit champignon est arrivé
aux etats-unis
il s'est répandu et dans l'espace de 20
ans on a perdu des milliards d'armes il
n'en a plus de châtaignier ou aux états
unis
donc on a perdu une espèce qui avait une
valeur économique une valeur culturelle
très très importante
en quelques années et ça ça risque de
nous arriver
[Musique]
au québec on a à peu près 60 espèces
d'arbres sont en perd une à toutes les 5
à 10 ans éventuellement il va nous en
manquait outre les champignons les
insectes et les maladies
une autre menace pèse sur nos forêts le
bouleversement du climat avec les
changements climatiques
on va perdre des espèces les espèces qui
peuvent pas résister à l'augmentation de
la chaleur vous regardez ici là vous
avez des conifères
on est en outaouais ya des conifères ces
espèces là sont des espèces boréale et
plus ça se réchauffe
- ils sont capables de compétitionner
avec les autres espèces et on va les
perdre
on repère des espèces aussi qui ne
tolère pas la sécheresse
si vous regardez encore ici auto il ya
beaucoup de boulot blanc bleu blanc
c'est une espèce qui est très sensibles
à la sécheresse
donc avec les prédictions des
changements climatiques fava devenait
plus sec
on va perdre les bouleaux blancs
christian b si nous invite donc à nous
projeter dans l'avenir quand vient le
temps de choisir des essences d'arbres
pour le reboisement souvent ce qu'on
fait quand on aménage des forêts on
simplifie la foire et on aménage des
forêts en fonction de ce qui est
commercial aujourd'hui sachant que quand
on plante qu'on établit une nouvelle
forêt cette forêt là va être récoltés
dans 50 60 ans et on n'a aucune idée
quelle va être la valeur commerciale de
ces espèces non
on se rend compte que quand on a une
diversité d'espèces on a une
productivité en moyenne plus grande que
si on avait la même espèce pour la
simple raison que chacune des espèces
ont des besoins en lumière ont des
besoins en eau ont des besoins en
éléments nutritifs qui sont différents
on un enracinement qui est pas la même
profondeur le boulot un harassement
beaucoup plus profond que lépine r donc
ils vont se partager le sol
epinal d'oise et moi je vais prendre ce
qui est en surface pour quelqu'un qui
veut couper le bois c'est quand même
plus compliqué le 6 à 4 5 6 espèces
c'est plus compliqué à gérer ce c'est
certain mais on est en train de
développer des approches au lieu d'avoir
des plantes et des espèces un peu
partout au hasard on pourrait planter
une espèce dans une rangée avec un autre
espèce dans un autre ange et on pourrait
récolter la première espèce qui pose
plus vite par exemple en premier et
laisser l'autre espèce se développer
donc à une possibilité de faire des
aménagements forestiers relativement
intensif avec un mélange d'espèces
quatrième temps remarqué beaucoup de
bois mort ici dans cette forêt là au sol
et debout et pendant longtemps le pour
un propriétaire forestier une forêt
privée c'était mal vu ça voulait dire
qu'on aménage à mal sa forêt où la
négliger leur propre puis même qu'à 24
économique mais maintenant on sait que
ce moment-là on roule très très
important dans l'écosystème parce que
c'est vraiment d'habitat pour plein
d'organismes des insectes des bactéries
des champignons des oiseaux des petits
mammifères est tellement que quand on
étudie la dynamique de ces bois monts au
locle
il résulte de bois mort on s'aperçoit
qu'en gourmand est souvent plus vivant
quant à elles vivent en terme de
biodiversité
deux députés
par ses recherches christian messier
interpelle d'ailleurs les propriétaires
de forêts privées
ils sont plus de 130 milles au québec
mais seulement 20% d'entre eux coupe du
bois sur leurs terres selon le chercheur
aménager la forêt est primordial pour la
maintenir en santé à long terme
j'ai commencé à travailler avec les
forestières dans différentes régions
pour acide peut-être convaincre un
certain nombre de propriétaires de
forêts privées de femmes des coupes pour
pour des revenus
mais pour permettre de planter des
espèces qui vont venir enrichir leurs
forêts qui vont leur permettre justement
d'avoir une meilleure résilience face à
des maladies à des insectes ce que
j'appelle souvent l'incertitude dans le
futur
[Musique]
au québec la très grande majorité du
bois est coupée en forêt publique
une richesse qui nous appartient à tous
et là aussi des changements de pratiques
s'imposent
on continue à faire des coupes à blanc
mais ce qu'on fait à la place de faire
de grandes coupes à blanc où on laisse
rien on laisse des arbres soient
individuels ou des îlots ce qu'on
appelle une rétention
parce qu'on a mesurée que dans les feux
de forêts naturelles
bien que ça brûlait de grande superficie
il laissait beaucoup d'îles au naturel à
partir de ces une ola on note dispersion
des graines qui permet de gérer la forêt
donc on a commencé à faire ça est-ce que
je suis satisfait de ce qu'on fait
actuellement non ou le fait encore je
dirais acide timidement ce genre de
coupe à blanc avec rotation on le fait à
peu près sur 10 % du territoire
on devrait le faire sur 100% du
territoire mais on le fait sur 10 %
évidemment quand on laisse des îlots des
arbres debout c'est du bois qu on les
colle pas un an et une perte mais c'est
une paire 30 m de bois mais c'est un
gain en termes de capacité de
régénération de la forêt capacité de
créer des habitants pour la biodiversité
et c'est du carbone aussi qu'on laisse
dans la forêt donc ça c'est important
qu'est ce que ce serait votre souhait
pour la foresterie de demain c'est de la
transformer pour que les forêts story ne
soit plus perçue comme un problème parce
qu'actuellement
quand vous parlez de faire restaurer aux
gens les gens rhodia c'est ce qui
détruit les forêts à sa coupe
on coupe les forains ont détruit les
forêts ce que j'aimerais que la
foresterie devient c'est une pratique
qui nous permet de trouver une solution
aux changements globaux donc il va
permettre d'accélérer l'adaptation de
nos forêts via la coop on enlève des
armes des espèces qui sont moins bien
adapté à ce qui s'en vient et on voit
les remplacer via la régénération
naturelle ou la plantation par des
espèces qui sont mieux adaptés aux
conditions qui s'en viennent donc on
parle d'une forêt story d'adaptation au
lieu du discours qu'on entend encore
aujourd'hui la foresterie ça détruit nos
forums
[Musique]